oopsy doopsy oopsy doopsy I'm oopsy
doopsy
oopsy doopsy Oh left sigh good evening
I'm Gloria Borger I wasn't planning to
make another video about this but then
Vox went ahead and published not one but
two articles about PewDiePie
I'm so sick of this guy Vox owns the
verge which means that this is actually
the third video in a week that they post
smearing him as an anti-semite and now
white supremacists wow they must really
like this guy
PT PI's ties to white supremacy spell
serious trouble for the future of
YouTube ignoring that incredible
headline just for a moment if you think
just for a second
they picked a photo where I'm blinking
as the main photo for this article as a
cheap attempt to make me look as bad as
possible then you're wrong okay this is
actually how I record all my videos and
in case you're new to my channel it's
just the thing I do okay so not sure
what happened here well let's read some
headlines to investigate because that's
the best way in the world to get your
facts
Peter Piper promotes Nazi propaganda
YouTube star Peter Piper emotes channel
with anti semantic content
Peter Peggy's shout-out to hateful
anti-semitic YouTube channel PD PI's
ties to white supremacy spells serious
trouble for the future of YouTube here's
what I actually said in my shout out
video
er who does great video essays about
Death Note which I really really enjoyed
so what actually happened a quick
rundown I already explained in another
video but I was getting so many
subscribers that I thought it would be
nice for me to shoutouts in smaller
channels it was at the end of the video
and I shouted out 28 channels now this
was clearly my mistake I should not have
picked that goddamn many channels
because obviously I'm not gonna go
through every single video in their past
like two year old videos just to make
sure that maybe they said something that
doesn't align with myself one of them
featured Nazi imagery and jokes and
that's why I decided to remove him from
the list and then ended it out of the
video I think most people would be
pretty sensible about a mistake like
this keeping all these things in mind
but oh no no oh no no that's not the
case it led to an absolute barrage on
Twitter I don't think I've gotten this
much attention on Twitter since says The
Wall Street Journal thing they must have
really thought they had me this time I
don't know people making these it was
insane claims about me saying I Shepard
legions of fortune or to neo-nazi
content it's an anime review that's the
main point of the video
love that Peter Piper T much openly says
I'm not see if that's me openly saying
I'm not see it's a pretty goddamn
cryptic way to put it this developer
from Ubisoft said enough is enough
gaming industry I'm going to need you to
send this dude you know exactly who you
are cut ties with him don't worry she's
just spreading her positivity guys
please don't be mean this is just
writing positivity
now she apparently removed that she's
working for Ubisoft
after this so I don't know if she
actually got fired enough bum bum bum I
responded in my first video saying that
I didn't actually know these references
and basically oh well this was pretty
dumb I'll delete him from the
recommendations that's pretty much all I
can do at this point thinking that would
be it but oh no no oh no no the number
one argument that was constant I've seen
this argument being thrown around
constantly on Twitter and in
and I'm just gonna use Huffington Post
as an example but so many people have
been using this argument against my
defense saying I actually didn't know PD
PI's excuse for promoting racist YouTube
content includes more racist content
saying that okay maybe he didn't know
about the 2-year old videos and the
videos on his other channel saying that
well the video that he recommended had
jokes about Heather Hayes death in it
and making fun of an autistic black guy
we have him now boys ladies and
gentlemen we got the video pointed to
Heather hares
how could he I don't know who this is
I'm sorry I don't mean to be
disrespectful I honestly genuinely have
no idea who this is I know about the
Charlottesville's Siddhant and I know
someone died there and basically the
verge wrote this as well as saying that
there was aerial footage of the moment
when a car drove through the crowd of
people during the white supremacist led
unites the right rally in
Charlottesville last year so this was
the video that I recommended
specifically I get it it sounds pretty
bad but let's just take a second to
watch what that footage look like that
victim will die of a heart attack and
then she will die by being struck by a
car however there's too much in a way
for a car to hit her because the
situation is impossible and that's the
cause of death as well the woman would
die of a heart attack
death flicks didn't get far enough into
reading the rules on the wikia page now
obviously I blurred the footage not
because I don't want to show it but
specifically because I don't want to
instantaneously transform 76 million
people into Nazis which is definitely
what's going to happen if anyone sees
that footage obviously I didn't know
about this footage I think most people
outside of the United States don't know
about this footage I tested it out on a
couple people just to make sure I wasn't
crazy but that was the case no one know
about this footage and ER put it in
there as a joke it's extremely edgy and
inappropriate joke and I would not have
publicly recommended this video if I
knew about it but the hidden reference
of it it's the joke that this really a
horrific footage most people won't even
recognize it that that's in there
without most people recognizing it is
the joke secret Nazi jokes everyone
they've been around for literally since
the age of the Internet
oh sorry and even just showing this
footage pushing for that this is white
supremacy is that this the reach is
still very far
this guy followed up with saying to the
trolls that's right if you criticize
someone you're a troll they're saying
p-type I didn't know who Heather hare
was last year he tweeted about a photo
of white nationalist marching with
ticket order saying this these guys
clearly watch one too many peopIe bids
now I don't remember tweeting this at
all to be honest what I did remember
tweeting was this I don't have a
high-res photo because I have a bot that
deletes all my tweet it's a long story
dear Nazis stop looking so identical to
me you're really not helping my case
they like this image that Huffington
Post used for the Charlottesville's
rally just look strangely a lot like me
that was all I joked about this doesn't
prove that I knew that aerial footage it
has nothing to do with it the second
argument was that in the description of
the video it had a race is edgy joking
that's right
the description how could I have been so
stupid the thing that everyone checks
constantly so these two facts is what
most people have been using online as
evidence against that oh he knew he knew
what he was doing okay it's like oh well
he made Nazi jokes in the past so
obviously he's 100% guilty
it's like logic conveniently gets thrown
out the window for the sake of lambasted
me and it's just you're really just
exposing yourself for having idiotic
ideas and cannot look more than two
second deeper into an issue just all of
this really justify calling me a white
supremacist by the box when have I ever
expressed myself in that way
now looking at the Vox article because
it's hilarious they can first of all
can't even get my name right I get it
it's really hard writing is hard it's
not expected from journalists PI
thigh-high pewdie PU bucks said talked
in this article about my alliance with
the alt-right
this is something I've been accused of
before and have said no that's not true
they mentioned they don't write the 29
times in this article it's almost like
they're obsessed with these things so
what are the evidence that ties me to
the old ride according to box well get
this guy's I don't even know if I should
bring this up because I don't know
I want to expose myself to this
hard-hitting evidence and facts that
there they got me with I reviewed jordan
Peterson's self health book first of all
Jordan Peterson is not alright he's
another figure that the media doesn't
like so they label him as all tried as a
way to discredit him he's repeatedly
disassociated himself with all Tryon
personalities and second of all
reviewing a book doesn't mean anything
it's not proof of anything
it's literally a self-help book it's the
least controversial thing I've read in
so long the second argument that Vox had
or evidence that I have ties to the old
writers because I follow people on
Twitter that they deem outright such as
Ben Shapiro and Laci green among others
that's right Laci green alt right here
or everyone you remember that her sex
educational videos deep diving Nazi
imagery you just got to dig a little
deeper very hidden references way more
hidden than er's Lowell according to Vox
being followed by PewDiePie means you're
all right so what if I follow Vox does
that mean Vox is all right can't wait to
see your response to this Vox I
basically have you in a corner now so
apparently the journalists of this
article of this reporter thought to
herself you know what this is I wrote
some garbage today but you know what not
dumb and I need to make it even more
stupid so she went to Twitter and wrote
as an addendum to my two recent articles
on the potential for serious extremist
radicalization that PewDiePie and is 76
million followers represent on YouTube
everyone who's watching this video
everyone that's subscribed at PewDiePie
represents serious radicalization
extremist radicalization seems like a
pretty fair description I mean the views
of this reporter comes across pretty
clear when it's not through the
editorial framework and she basically
says that a kind reader pointed out this
recording of a stream in which Peter
pipe lays pablor with a player and it's
this guy with a I don't know how to
explain it it's this guy with the
parody of a Jew image and an Jew mocking
name basically this person is so stupid
I honestly genuinely feel bad for her
whether or not he knew he apparently
hangs out in gaming communities where
it's possible to game with people using
anti-semitic slurs and avatars it's a
public video game and I didn't even
interact with this guy it's like holding
me accountable for going outside and
having the views with other people I've
even seen this clip a hundred times I
didn't even notice the guy's name I
[Laughter]
think it's such a great example of me
being painted as an anti-semite and
being painted as a Nazi when all I'm
doing is playing video games having fun
I didn't see this guy I watched it a
hundred times I never saw this guy and
even then I have nothing that doesn't
prove anything
maybe feet up I didn't realize this was
an anti-semitic handle or he did but
didn't care enough to exit the game I
should have done the right thing guys I
should have just exited the game
immediately this whole thing is this a
giant guilty by association reviewing a
guy's book ah
how could he playing in a public video
game ah following someone on Twitter
just cuz you interact with someone
online doesn't mean you endorse all of
their views that's such an incredibly
stupid thing to think she even pointed
out that the harassment I've got any
response from PewDiePie supporters
especially bears out all the points
being made in the second article being
criticized is not harassment finally I
wanted to take a look at the bigger
picture here
you know this controversy has more or
less passed at this point so what really
were the effects the main thing that I
got Christmas that criticized for this
shoutout was how incredibly
irresponsible it was for me to recommend
this channel and in a way I can't
understand at least that argument but
people saying that I was shepherding
legions of 14 year olds towards neo-nazi
content and the verge saying that
hundred and
fifteen used thousand subscribers which
is just blatantly false it was fifteen
thousand who some of whom may be
extremely young turning into
anti-semitic hateful content appointing
people to CERN channels especially ones
built on hateful content further
radicalized young viewers on YouTube
that was the effect of this now this is
just blatantly not true even if you
watch yours videos yes they have very
edgy jokes and I'm not here to debate it
anything about who he is but the main
point of his videos at least you could
argue are not about these political
issues and I think that's why you went
over my head to recommend this channel
because I'm just here for the sweet
anime okay that's all I really care
about but regardless of that twelve
thousand people subscribe after me
recommending this channel and then it
was immediately diffing after that you
can see it here it was going down but
then the media comes into the picture
they mention him in every single article
I've seen they bring up er's channel and
there you go he gets fourteen thousand
subscribers er should really honestly
just thank the media for giving him more
a bigger shout-out than I did
I'm extremely irresponsible you are
aware of the damages that you are saying
it's costing but you're causing more
damage it's the basic strives and effect
of the more you try and cover something
up then the bigger it gets and they're
not they're not unaware of this it's
pretty obvious that they know how this
works at this point but people don't
care people just want to be outraged
online people just want to get clicks
online and it's the same thing with
these articles finally I wanted to end
on on notes about why I think Vox is
going after me and it's not me saying
this is concrete evidence to why you
know I definitely have made mistakes and
I deserve to be criticized when I mess
up but I think part of the reason why I
mean especially is getting so much I
don't know what to call it slander it's
because I have more influence than a lot
of media
let's that's not me flexing again that's
a fact and they hate that The Wall
Street Journal posted earlier this year
I know Wall Street Journal Vox media on
pace to miss revenue target as digital
advertising disappoints the expected Vox
media shortfall is another sign that the
digital media industry is struggling to
adapt to the reality that online ad
growth is becoming harder to come by
especially as tech firms such as
Facebook Google and Amazon corner of the
market are one concern for Vox media
much like other digital firms is that
revenue from sponsored content isn't
growing as fast as it once did ever
since the year 2000 a newspaper
advertising revenue in the USA has just
completely plummeted I mean 50 years of
progress as completely went out the
window
according to the Guardian it's estimated
that every dollar spent on advert in the
Western world 90 percent of that goes to
Google and Facebook 90 percent keeping
that in mind you have the biggest crater
on YouTube how can we make him and
YouTube look bad at the same time
pewdiepie ties to white supremacy spells
serious trouble for the future of
YouTube I don't mean to get into oh this
is why I obviously don't know I think
this headline makes a lot more sense
keeping these things in mind a lot of
people point to my controversies at
stunts as something that I deliberately
do to boost myself and my brand to get
more subscribers peter pine there was
controversial anti-semitic views to gain
subscribers stunt backfires big time
that's right it was a stunt to recommend
a channel another article saying why why
has YouTube's biggest are not being
cancelled yet we cannot keep letting him
get away with these rides no one's
stopping him the reason why despite all
my controversies that I'm still so
popular is because fans know who I am
the people who actually know my videos
and know me know that all these things
that people say in the media just aren't
true and when I have made mistakes in
the past I've apologized and moved
forward from it and moved on from it my
fans don't look at the world with the
insane lens that everyone is an enemy
that needs to be publicly destroyed by
running these articles about me smearing
my name and calling me white
supremacists calling me racist
you are watering down the definition of
these words by keep calling me all these
things these words will no longer carry
the same meaning and in a way you are
doing these people that are actually
racist and anti-semitic a favor and I
don't doubt that there are races an
anti-semite in the world but you're
looking at the wrong places
and people know it you are also hurting
your own brand and as a news outlet you
are just losing your credibility because
people know this isn't true and that's
probably the number one thing you'd care
about protecting as a media outlet is
that what you're saying the check is
actually true what you're saying is
actually unbiased but you spell it out
so clearly that that's not the case
Fox doesn't allow comments on their
articles gee I wonder why if you go on
Twitter and check the replies the
response is pretty unanimous and that's
even coming from people that are fans of
Vox saying as a left winger and fan of
many Vox production I've become every
time more disappointed with articles
about PewDiePie's ties to be all right
it's just thin connections being
extrapolated over and over again this
isn't it's not me picking one if you go
through its the general consensus from
these articles the more the mainstream
media talks about me the more I just
gain from it and that's not me
benefiting from controversies that's
because people know these are smear
campaigns and people are tired of it
people can't stand these articles
anymore you can kick and scream PT
prides not C all you want but it's not
gonna change that fact but I think most
importantly out of all days the number
one thing that I want people to take out
of this is subscribe to PewDiePie that's
right PewDiePie now at 77 million
subscribers I'm gonna rate Vox media a
zero
I'm Gloria Borger and this is Gloria
Borger house